joining us down the Continental Tire
coaches corner he's the Kentucky head
coach John Calipari blown out by Duke in
the first game of the seat I guess I
should be saying good things about him
since he's in the studio with us six
Final Fours won the title in 2012 guys
[Music]
so you start off with I get buried by
Duke is that right
yeah yeah and you just hit Pauley right
in the face white morning yeah how you
doing doing all right how are you good
what do you uh what are you here on the
street here in Minneapolis when people
see you I just got here oh yeah and I
walked in and I think people are excited
you know it's the Final Four your hair
looks like you've been up for oh my god
your hair looks great you have makeup on
I see why didn't I get makeup you don't
need it oh yeah yeah yeah you probably
have a tanning bed don't you are you
crazy
probably got a style and they've never
knew you put oil on I know from
Pittsburgh gotta clean up a fire at a
tanning bed yeah what do you think of
your Steelers Mike Tomlin is the best
and unfortunate they go through some
things like every team but they'll
figure it out it's just Steelers it's
just the others they'll have a chance to
be in the you know Super Bowl win the
championship they'll be there but when
you have these coaches where you have
players who are they're under contract I
mean it's different for you know college
basketball coach if you have a problem
sometimes you're stuck with the problem
and that's it feels like that that was
the way with Mike Talman certainly with
Antonio Brown well there's nothing you
can do our Le'Veon Bell you know I don't
know if it's as much as the coaches the
management was it a contract you know
what was it what I don't know all the
particulars I just know mike is a good
man but this you know you didn't deal
with this too much in the NBA did you
you know I I told you the story I mean
the dif
between college and the NBA in college
you're teaching life skills you're
you're you're counseling kids your
counsel aggressively sit them out games
at times just sit them out of practice
and if it's really bad tell them you
can't be a part of this yeah in the NBA
if the guys the same way you start him
you get him shots promote him in the
media so you can trade off I mean it's a
totally different approach to it
have you ever purposely tried to end a
practice early for something that he
wanted to do on your own we Bob Knight
entered a practice he got angry at a kid
just so he could go hunting Chris beard
was here yesterday and he talked about
how he entered a practice so he could go
get something to eat you ever done that
in Kentucky not really I can't remember
but you know if I have a radio show they
make me do this I'm like guys I got to
go to the end of practice they'll do
shooting drills do the shooting stuff I
gotta go they got me doing radio here
guys so I've done that are you more
important in practice or in the game I
would like to think in practice because
you want your players to go to the
training in the game like don't worry
about the opponent don't worry about the
TV don't worry about the tournament just
go to your training so I think you're
more important in the games that in
practice games are more of a chess match
they do something you know you get in a
game and and all of a sudden you have to
change what you're doing to finish the
game like you you're playing of playing
so-and-so and so-and-so and it by the
end of the game you're like look let's
just win this game and we'll figure it
out after I've that happens a lot in
these games but I think the practices
are where the games are won or lost
John Calipari the Kentucky head coach
joining us here in the studio nice
studio got here that's uh that's where
they're gonna play the final four right
what socks do you have mine what socks
yeah
Under Armour okay yeah okay yeah sorry
inside out of the right no no no they're
good they're good
usually you wear them one way and then
because you don't want to wash him you
turn them over and run the other way
which I've seen here before I don't have
an apparel deal like if you decide to
get an Under Armour deal obviously or
you wouldn't know you asked me that I
could have said no I got socks on I wear
adidas I wear Nike whoever once again
exactly so you're on schedule do you
want scholarship yeah your whole life
yeah okay but if you didn't have an
apparel deal with Nike you probably
couldn't get dressed in the morning
could you well I'd have underworld what
do you think Nikes gonna offer Zion
Williamson what do you think he's worth
well do you remember when Nike did what
they did with tiger and everybody was up
in arms they couldn't believe it you
know and they got a deal did he do they
got a deal I would say and and I'll be
honest with you if we recruited Zion I
probably missed him a little bit I knew
he was gonna be good
I didn't know he was gonna be this good
I knew he could dominate but not like
he's done and when we played against him
I walked off the court and I said I
missed on another one I know I mean I
know he'd be good you know what I'm
saying I watched him I said he's gonna
be I he's gonna be good the kids off the
chain how did you find out he wouldn't
go into Kentucky um I can't remember
probably told us we we get told no many
more times when we get told yes
everybody talks about they get everybody
that was so untrue I mean but it's
probably someone called us and I wish
them luck and you know I can't remember
their I hear know so much who broke your
heart Tom Izzo said he cried when he
lost Chris Weber recruit ever made you
that you lost made you cry no no sad
because they don't take it personal it's
not it's their family if you don't want
to play for me I get it go you know I
wish you luck you know I mean I'm not
gonna get mad at a kid I'm not gonna I
can't believe you did this to me it's
not about me if they think their best
opportunity to read
their dreams is with with our program
and how we do it and we don't do it like
everybody else I mean it's hard and it's
a grind and you're not gonna you know if
you don't guard you're not gonna play
and are you okay lie to you what's that
are you lied to um I don't think so
there's like we think that if someone if
someone tells me a lie and I know it's a
lie
then I'll walk out of the home and say
you know what they just did they're not
telling the truth like like for example
I may say to a family now that we're
involved the avalanche is gonna happen
and they go what avalanche we're gonna
get killed by everybody everybody's
gonna come in and kill us and if is
that's what's happened most families to
say you have everybody's talked about
you guys and this and this
if someone says now they don't say
anything about you I walk in move on
what's the reaction to the lifetime
contract been what lifetime what
happened yeah I saw the headline you got
a lifetime deal with Kentucky Congrats a
lifetime deal did declare me dead in
three years I mean what is a lifetime I
didn't label it a lifetime deal somebody
else did I know I didn't labeled a
lifetime deal so someone must have I
mean here's the thing
do you have a contract here you die no
Ben it's not a lifetime that's what I
say look I so people there have been
people that have said things about this
thing and haven't even read it what the
university did months ago the beginning
of the year their thing was we want you
to finish your career here what would
that look like well I'm in the middle of
the season I don't know what it would
look like so they came at me and said
what could it look like this the meeting
took 15 minutes between Dwayne Peavy and
why are you yelling I'm yelling
I like y'all at you it took 15 minutes
he said could it look like this I said
yeah that would be good and I spruced it
up a little bit you have to you know you
do yeah
but the reality of it is it's it's not
till I die it's not that I'm gonna be in
a walker trying to coach its you finish
your career here this is what it looked
like this and that was it I mean and and
again let me say this can I say
something else you
ready to speak again yeah go ahead my
leverage is what I've done at each
school it's not that this school called
or that program called or that NBA team
that's not my level my leverage is what
I've done at the programs and I do talk
to people and the reason I talk to
people have relationships with most of
them and if it's an NBA team I'm gonna
probably call that God and pick some of
my players so yeah I do but it's it's it
was blown up and and it came out so we
had to respond to it but the university
has been good to me
I appreciate what they've done for me
hopefully I've done something good there
that led them to say we want you to
finish your career here and it's been a
pretty good run can I speak now no okay
somebody else one of the Dennis poly did
you want to ask him about UCLA something
yes or no did UCLA offer you a contract
no no we look okay but there are numbers
attached to this it's there if there are
numbers that are not true they're not
true you didn't entertain us I know each
other because we worked on committees
okay but no that's not true
you didn't you didn't entertain anything
with UCLA no we dan and I talked he
talked to our ad said let's talk and we
talked about the culture of a big-time
basketball program so they're gonna do
fine and it's it is what it is I'll say
it again the relationships that I have
in this profession over all these years
you know I'm gonna talk to people and at
the end of every year this stuff happens
my leverage is not another another
program it's what I've done whether I
was whatever program it's what I've done
on the court with our kids what we've
done can I start on the graduation right
no no we're not doing that this time
around
players salaries how much they made
graduation rate now we've been down this
road many times
Lakers reach out to you no no no
interest in going back to no I you're
good I'm where I want to be good I'm
coach knows you I believed you when you
told me this is where you don't look for
another offer you don't want to coach
anyplace else that's why when I saw the
why would why would I why would I want
to leave Kentucky that's when all of us
asked ourselves when the rumor came out
yeah I mean why would i but well I talk
to people sure I mean what do I know I
don't talk to you and I don't talk to
you and I'm not talking and then I call
can you draft my guy no you wouldn't
talk to me when I wanted to talk to you
I'm not gonna you create relationships
in this thing yeah and the relationships
you have whether it be with owners GM's
athletic directors college presidents
important that we're able to reach out
and help our kids I'm happy for you oh
my gosh what'd you do hesitate well no
no I'm happy for you you know there's
still something there's still some loose
ends there UCLA but you know I don't
there was numbers attached to it that's
why I don't know where they came from I
don't know where they came from either
Oh what should get someone how could
someone have an opinion on this quote
lifetime contract if no one has seen it
yet you haven't seen it you don't know
well he shouldn't have something till
he's 90 what can I have a contract to
him I'm hoping I'm living in five years
and B that's you it's it's just is gone
but are you gonna get a statue rising a
little bit yeah a little bit
are you gonna get a rising probably
you're polarizing on polls know you're
really polarized I are you get a statue
of Kentucky's that in your lifetime
country no because we have coach Joby
Hall statue right and I have to go in
it's part of my job to wipe it up when I
go in the office if there's any bird
doo-doo on it I got to get that off but
he has his statue out in front
of our of our lodge I got I got her knee
Thompson coming in so I got to take a
break I know all right no no why me stay
there but it'll be weird cuz Ernie's
gonna sit on your lap okay all right
Congrats on the lifetime deal there and
it's shame UCLA didn't work out we'll
take a break who's John Calipari four
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]